i played david fisher this is pretty
much my first experience in front of a
camera of any
substance
i think the show has uh maybe encouraged
me to employ some of my dark sense of
humor but i think it was already kind of
dark
you don't happen to have mr romano's
foot on you do you
david is someone who's pretty much in a
state of conflict over
every fundamental aspect of his life
there's a concept
his sexuality his relationship to his
family to his work
so he's a great great character don't
you know i think you're beautiful
no and kind and smart and
loving you didn't know that
no i think people they want to express
the fact that they're thankful that the
character exists and they thank me for
my role in that
the guy's not incidentally gay he's not
uh
always just he's not like the
understanding neighbor upstairs with the
little dog he's not
a lampoon you know he's like a real
person with a real relationship
amen so did we just what do we just do
we just get married
no seems kind of like we did yeah well
don't overthink it and i recognize that
he's a unique character in terms of his
conflicted and complicated relationship
to his sexuality
as well as his work his spirituality his
family i don't think a character
like david has ever been given
equal time you know in the way that
david is
that's exciting for me as an actor it's
creepy it's halloween every day here
it's totally weird
casket climber it's tough to consider
the
the notion that people spend so much
time around corpses more time with dead
bodies than living ones
and i i wouldn't go so so far as to say
that it's like
being a car mechanic i mean these are
human beings but one thing a guy said in
this
book called the undertaking thomas hardy
the dead don't care
you know they're gone it's just a body i
think i think people who spend that much
time
around dead bodies to approach it that
[Music]
way